the lesser prairie chicken is at the  center of a maelstrom lawsuits  regulatory battles legislative fights  the bone of contention how to protect  the threatened bird and regulate the use  of its territory in five states Kansas  New Mexico Texas Oklahoma and Colorado  lesser prairie chickens spend the mating  season on what are called Lex a lek is  kind of a dance floor where the male's  come to strut and attract a mate in the  blonde fairy grasses the male's show off  their skills feather flapping foot  stomping air sac bulging the females  gather around the lek watching the most  impressive males will breed with up to  80 percent of the females that means  many males leave the dance floor  frustrated and waiting to try again next  year